okay four people joining this livestream
we are going to be talking about some
natural language processing and open
language and in particular about text
normalization and I think Etienne said
he had something to show here so let me
let him go ahead and share his screen
yep
okay so we came up with a need of
additional text normalizing function
which you might want to clear your email
email off your screen that's true sounds
good what let me just go in another
space up here we go yeah sorry for the
external sound yes so we already have a
function that kind of do some sort of
normalizing like remove diacritics
transliterate you know to lowercase
man-slut right is not complete and
that's been a ongoing issue which I
thought we had found I thought somebody
was trying to do the remaining languages
that was something that Alan Joyce had I
think some student he person who was
looking at some of the languages which
we cannot successfully transliterate
yeah I know Francisco you and and
someone else to get past an initial
improvement there transliterate and I
think there was still an ongoing
secondary project so there was this
student who was going to do something on
this I don't know whatever happened to
that I mean it requires some research
about these languages right so I mean to
see an example of how this fails just do
um something like come word translation
if you did if you just type this at him
oh yeah word translation oh I don't know
somewhere that is like quotes fish comma
all
and why it's a slow fee okay there we go
now just say transliterate percent
Snapple no well I don't know I don't
think so
okay so now what you see is mostly it's
worked but like Burmese it didn't work
more northern that's to write some with
characters right so there should be
there should be a romanization mapping
which i thought was in cldr whatever it
is but apparently it isn't and it
actually requires some research for the
more obscure languages right all this
year a violent start and we have stated
that is viable at some point but of
course we transliteration goes for some
cases right so so there was the student
who was supposedly going to work on that
what happened to that do you no no I so
why don't you find out from Alan because
if that if somebody just forgot to
contact them then that would be a shame
but you know I'm sorry no Jean no
comment about concentration it's a
tricky function like many language
there's several possible consideration
and I know I know we did some tests so
to update a long word classifier I'm
here did some tests to you know just
take some text and transliterated you
know to make it more robust so it works
also on transliterated korean let's say
and it wasn't you know it results in
fortunately i think that compression
like lucky speaks speaks Persian so he
tried and he said oh I wouldn't trust
iterate it like that well he disagrees
with the cldr transliteration is yes yes
yes when he speaks with his friends
using these alphabets you wouldn't use
this from situation also we should be
aware that in some cases cldr doesn't
have the transliteration for the
language but only for the script
and we are falling back to the script so
that it's also an important differences
oh I see so I'm it was an Arabic one for
person because it is Arabic alphabet
well that's them probably totally wrong
yes for example we had that issue before
for Russian because cldr didn't consider
Russian really but they then they added
also Russians and how do we specify and
transliterate that it is the language as
opposed to just his a string look at the
character set so right now if we have
this drink we use the default
transliteration into Latin which there
is one for that but we can specify also
the language itself and in the cases we
don't have the language we try to fall
back to the script so in translate right
we can specify language or something or
Allah yes so it takes a source and a
destination language this is actually
trained us to be a it could be string I
think all that looks like a bug then
Japanese yeah well so I don't understand
why that's coming out red because it's
in the documentation I'll take a look at
that that shouldn't be going like that
okay I guess that's all separated yeah
that that's not for the Oh main
discussion but that's something that we
should be fitting so this was okay over
related function this they are not
normalizing this is just information
about character so that's something we
need as well so to two things we're
going to discuss normalizing and
information about characters okay so
these are just some standards use
somewhere else from ICU okay so what
were so and by the way does this came up
so it was a need for example when we're
converting models so try to remember it
was Bert or dg2 or something like that
they were using some of this classic
normalization before so so we need in
this function so two things we need
let's let's start by text memorization
first is a function that it just gives
text normalize everything and be able to
put some some method so so we thought of
calling that by the way we already had
some sort of brain stop meeting with
with Nick and few others and we came out
like just just the name text normalize
that could potentially involve you know
also remove the architects lower K is
like this sort of things
what's the demise what would the default
clicks normalized to good question I
don't know maybe one of these four that
is a most used
so when you do NFC text normalization
the thing that will come out is
human-like uman looks like text is that
correct or not
yeah yeah it's just for example if I if
I had new lines double new lines you
know weird paragraph markers and things
would text normalize do something to
those I don't know these things I was
actually but I assume not I know that I
understand but I mean here's my point my
point is that there are structured
documents where the structure contains
information you get what I'm saying and
where for example feeding it into a
neural net you know the neuron that is
unlikely to pick up on that structure
and you know the issue is do we want to
encode that structure um the UM for you
know in a way that can be readily picked
up by a text to text system for example
tokenization which is another turn off
the normalization applies to sentences
here if you have paragraphs you can
first split into paragraph and then
normalize as the very end
I mean Avenue but maybe someone here
maybe Francisco or you know someone
knows they stand out are part of the
transliteration steps so its first
normalized to something thermally then
goes to the normalization to the
translation tables back so I think some
of this normalization are ignored a bit
say for example change of line that
thing of cards now by this normalization
but okay so so hold on let me just look
at these stuff I mean this seems like a
highly sensible function I don't have
any problem with this function and what
the one argument forms should do I don't
know maybe
we shouldn't have a one argument form
initially I'm looking at these I'd
understand item 8 fix surrogates by the
way in item 7 there's a question of what
to do with multiple line breaks but I
guess you're just leaving those and in
this default yeah these were all the
things that I think just you cheated
that found that so this one was found
from a python library what it's the
Python library is called fixed text for
you so these were like other things that
that could that we could have to make it
better but these were not absolutely
necessary for the model conversion the
absolute necessary was the NFC and fkc I
understand but we're not just trying to
solve the problem of converting today's
model okay so so okay
what is item eight so I well I mean is
that utf-8 conversion or something or
what is that what I somebody here no
okay so the issue is many of these know
nets are probably gonna choke if there's
a 16-bit emoji in the string so true
statement yes okay so what do we want to
do when we normalize the 16-bit emoji
this will be more on the tokenization
part like no network internet encoder oh
by the way this these things should be
able to work in net encoders as well but
but but currently net encoder as
vocabulary and so it will just ignore if
this is something that is not in this
vocabulary you mean a character level in
vocabulary
yes okay so again I want to come back to
what do we do with the 16-bit I mean
what the output of text normal eyes is
supposed to be what ASCII text or what
just a string no no necessarily ASCII
text no okay
I think it's just a string to string
information exactly everything that we
chicks or any other things we don't
really care about the format right we
are all unicode and that's why i'm not
sure if these things are relevant that
doesn't change an internal structure of
how we store the text if it's ggf 816
whatever we have our way to encode
string that's the way it is and we just
process the strings right but the net
encoder
you can't take our encoding of the
string and tournament something suitable
for the neuron that yes and that's
something I think there's something
separate yes okay the large scale
problem we are trying to solve here is
what oh sorry no no go ahead like the
word naive if you if you put you know
it's it's crazy diacritics on it you're
saying if you put those crazy diacritics
that's going to be a unicode character
that will confuse the net encoder or the
actual network confusing not really you
could train with full full text and I
believe a capillary is just processing
that will help the learning afterward
because we already know that people use
you know don't prove their critiques oh
yeah right so okay yeah so this
normalization so there is a standard
hopefully this NFC thing for what
normalization does and it seems like
there is some pretty you know like curly
quotes uncurling quotes that seems like
a pretty obvious one for example yes
right although I mean that's listed
there as item five although it is not
self-evident to me that you know you
lose information when you're uncurl
quotes I mean so it's not obvious that
it's a good thing so then you're on that
dot that's always a trade off yeah it's
a huge amount of data and
diverse data which is rare then you keep
everything and it will do better but
most of the case you have not enough
data I mean as much as you would like
and o-o-or data that is not diverse
enough so then we already clearly quote
and then when you give a non Cali quote
you can say no idea what to do yeah I
understand all the time right
okay so look I understand the point of
this function seems sensible obviously
we'll have to get some sensible list of
what the actual targets are and I would
think I mean the only thing I wonder
about is whether there are you know
whether that second argument represents
a target or transformation because for
example you could imagine you know uncle
quotes is a text normalized I mean
that's a text normalized action whereas
lowercase is a text normalized
destination okay what I'm saying yes we
are going to this for example T
lowercase to uppercase in some cases you
need to consider the target language
also you don't for example the normal
forms don't need to consider any
language because they work at few
unicode level but lowercase might be
different depending on the language okay
but I'm also making the point that are
you describing the endpoint like the
normal forms you're describing the end
point whereas uncurling quotes you're
describing the action yes I mean that
could say yeah so I think should be
endpoint all the time okay so now it's
called uncurled quotes so instead of
remove diacritics it would be diacritics
removed exactly okay and quotes uncurled
poetically and then
you'll be able to make a list uncurled
presumably you've been able to make a
mist our credits removed quotes uncurled
in a list - yeah to basically have
something where and some things would
basically win over others I mean this
yeah this is already functioned for that
we do we just extension because I don't
think would have a function called now I
agree just and there's a to lowercase as
well so this is just a sort of a batch
way of doing text normalization
including for these named text
normalization outcomes make sense yep I
think that makes complete sense yeah
okay okay so okay maybe you can talk
about okay the second thing was about
extracting features from characters so
we read no bunch of things about some
characters like actually the function of
a character named no no let me know this
one okay no there's character greater
this what is AP comma oh I see that
that's that's a list so now we have
related function is to activate which is
letting that character take don't we
have character data
no that's function alpha and we have the
explosive entity character which uses
this current debate internally they did
something so let's say okay Lance and
smaller to a it's a character yep and
it's got various properties exactly so
actually the idea would be to kind of
bring this into a function a top level
function that is fast just the way that
it'll be used that it will process you
know huge amount of text to extract
features like we would encode if it's
Latino not by by an integer would encode
you will incur a bunch of stuff and give
that to whatever model what is it
you want you want something that
generates a feature vector for each
character exactly exactly
feature vector for each character okay
and and why exactly is that not just a
net encoder of some kind or a feature
extractor he should be anything coder as
well yes but you might want to use that
and not necessarily with networks okay
so what about a feature extractor but
why isn't I think we have to be able to
do a custom one feature extract are
usually a name you know a more
high-level name thing like we want to be
able to say I want the first element of
the feature vector to tell if it's Latin
or not I want to second the amen to say
if it's capital or not I won't I mean we
could have a a generic feature extractor
that gives all the data but Unni don't
want all the data you want just you know
four of them okay let me understand what
you're proposing so first of all there
are certain attributes that characters
have which that properties list seems
very slim or is it not is that is that
what what is in this cldr database those
can we look just do data set of that
just instead of properties just say data
set okay can we try something looked
like more exotic instead of an a could
you try the same thing but but let's say
I don't know try this yeah okay
why the hell are those language
frequencies integers
I do not understand that at all that
looks like a bug they should be
fractions right Francisco can you
comment on that yes that that's legacy
data we have yes we'll make them
fractions please sure sure sure they
mean nothing but related a relative
frequency which so can we fix that
please I'm not sure if this is
documented or not but I think yeah we
should just fix that because that's
useless okay but let's take a look at
this so what other things would you like
to have other than what's in here idea
okay I mean nothing yes
lowercase uppercase yes if it's a letter
if it's a number so I don't know if this
is there or not like character no just
look you can get to as a character yeah
- hmm that's weird and that's a bug
that's a bug you should report that that
thing with the - is a bug so but before
you do that just say from character code
14,000 okay now let's do the same thing
with with your
for God's sake well that's underwhelming
that's a bug let's find out what
happened to it
so like the category there there should
be a category property for that thing
right can you find out what it thinks it
is or is there a way of getting to the
internal character data function
Francisco so only with anything I say
okay so why do you think that didn't
work that thing with that random Chinese
character could we just try I mean okay
so that's a bug anyway that has to be
tracked down okay that's a bug of some
kind but notice that
already had a bug when it tried to make
the the yeah I think that character is I
think what it's doing is that carrot has
a name and it should be using the name
try character name of that creature
their name curtain name okay now try the
control equals of that thing
a bunch of bugs around us that's not
gonna help
oops gonna help a bunch of bugs to do
with the way that whole hold on hold on
let's characterize these bugs okay the
character names should be able to be
interpreted I think for sure the
interpreter should work for that
character but then what I want to
understand is your feature vectors what
is the difference between what you want
to get out in the feature vector and
what the entity value thing does to
understand it yeah yeah yeah I'm trying
to say I mean one difference that it
should probably be at least in the net
encoder it should not be lowercase
letter it should be an integer that's
not what we're gonna put in this
function right no so maybe what we will
need is a mapping or for these
categories some kind of name that could
be converted into that the categories
themselves become entities that makes
sense that the possible outcomes from
the categories become entities and that
then you have a mapping table that says
lowercase letter is a one you know ran a
mathematical character is a seven etc
not what you think you need a ten
eventually yes yes therefore net encoder
it has to be directly integers you
cannot be okay I understand that but I'm
asking is the only thing you're keying
into the category or you King into other
attributes here no other attributes I
mean no many things I want to know like
which I bet it is I wanna know if it's
lowercase or not at all let's see if
it's integer I want to see another
application depend of the reputation
okay so what is it that you thought you
wanted coming into this meeting with
character data what is that you wanted
them mostly if this is the thing that I
described so if it's Latino know what
what's the real reason you're talking
about character interest because you
don't think the additive property
as fast enough or what oh no we need
needs okay why do you need it why is it
any different from the entity property
look up what is the function absolutely
unusual at here at here stop I want to
understand is the only objection that
it's not fast enough where is there an
objection about functionality
I didn't look enough and detail about
this property to know if there's some
additional property we need okay fine I
think it's mostly packaging speed and
performance thing yes okay okay well so
considering we already have the ICU
library in the system they will I see
well 18 wanted was a function that
access information okay which is
otherwise known as character data with
the second argument right which is the
equivalent of entity value of the
character entity comma the second
argument I mean doesn't exist in which
no I understand that we were going to
have that under some reason we don't
have that because instead we have the
entity property version and I think it's
perfectly conceivable this is a basic
enough thing and I think that it makes
sense to do something which is not a
pure entity value thing because for
example we could do character data with
a string that has multiple characters in
it and have it come out with a list and
all those kinds of things yes exactly
exactly there was already actually so
many characters in young anyway so this
was kind of an introductory meeting and
also to set up you know reduction to I
mean I'm sure there would be more design
happening so every person wanted answers
was should we do this or not and we
should do it okay back down to the
bottom okay
so we've got a bunch of bugs here the
idea of exposing character data it seems
like a good idea
it seems extremely straightforward for
the reasons that that Francisco has said
right right there well they are only
shown with exposing character data
itself would be too
a matter of designing if we are going to
accept their the standard names or not
because if you see the standard name of
characters are at bully and more complex
you scroll down please yeah to the ones
that actually work so if you see the
full form for example of this latin
small letter e with baracy so if you
take the letter
well I noticed bizarrely okay it's got a
name but it doesn't have the standard
name let's do it in that dataset we
should move on but okay all right yes we
never listen to something there but also
your phone right but so there's some
reason so it might be for example
problematic to make a difference between
a list of characters as a single string
or right so I think then character die I
get the I get the point
that's why I think character data should
simply work on the character string
do you see what I'm saying it should not
deal with the standard names it should
get what it should be able to do is just
like character name character name
returns the standard name doesn't it not
dream it the entity but right now that's
wrong yes okay so that has to be uniform
iso character name returns the standard
name character data does not take
standard names
it could have as one of its properties
standard name so that it could return
that you know what I'm saying
it's redundant with character named
because character name will do the same
thing that make sense
okay so character data simply takes a
character string and tells you how many
characters I'm sorry or many chances can
just string many of any number of
characters and it will produce a list I
mean this is very similar to two so
character data there would be a second
argument to character data which would
make it behave like two character code
did you see what I'm saying
did you understand yeah yeah yeah so you
mean it would say Unicode code for
example or you call a Unicode or
something as a second argument right and
that would actually just return the the
Unicode values actually yeah sure or
actually
could just say character coder now
notice that character codes in general
need a character encoding really saying
which is no no look our own strings do
not need character encodings because our
own strings actually operating in the
system are all as it happens internally
encoded in unicode but every character
in that string has a definite you know
is a definite character right it's not
like we've got this bit pattern and
today it means alpha and tomorrow it
means you know Chinese schwa or
something right
did you get what I'm saying but when we
import character strings we have to
worry about what their encoding that was
used for them was when they are
operating inside our system we do not
have to worry about character encoding
so I'm guessing character data does not
have to worry about character encoding
no words did you get what I'm saying but
yes III agree we should go to that so we
can only have the unicode value so if
you need to do all their operations you
would use the regular from character
code okay what else is that well there's
some okay so sorry
before you continue and what will be the
default one argument for character data
or we long I don't know I'm not sure it
has one okay okay great
so
we should do it great and the question
is who's gonna do it
I mean I assume that this exposure is I
mean Francisco has already worked on
this stuff right Hey
yes character data is part of what we
were planning to do after the news date
etc and character data well it's
actually after another break but yes
playing great and would be to give you
know discuss if if needed but but
they're not doing text normalized that's
a different that's somebody different
that's you guys doing text normalize
right that's I mean I don't know if it
should be us that's also you see I
library type thing right okay you have
to talk about that I don't know who the
right person to do it is okay well you
guys can figure out this I mean it
doesn't look like this is very hard yeah
I mean if needed to cheat I can help or
do stuff um but but you know if it makes
more sense to be Francisco or Nick well
okay what else is there to figure out
here okay I mean this is where the main
thing then I mean there's always some
extra things we'll be discussing with
your home lately
we can go in actually long discussions
maybe we should not have to talk about
this but this is important okay yeah so
this is we're kind of brainstorming it
recently I mean it's very early thoughts
about how to extend the thing yeah
sorcerer to patent magic for example
synonyms is one of the thing actually
it's one is open is one of the thing we
could we could have to almost synonyms
yeah our synonyms are not great because
there's no I mean we should see but
there's no it's for more data right so
there's no weights cited on each thing
so in some case you have so many signer
names that are a lot of ambiguity I mean
this is pretty clear that process is by
but sometimes you have a word that is
not should find an example
well I mean there's word sense you you
should be able to have that word look we
have word sense entities right you
understand by has many senses so if you
say how do we get to this um I think if
you just said no but now say I don't
know how you get criticized that that
comes out Nick that's for you I mean a
little surprise that doesn't come out in
terms of entities nowadays I think they
there's a plan to do that as the the
entity where daily gets switched over
because there's two different word
sources and I haven't spoken with that
one recently about that but I can check
on the status i don't you why don't you
check on that because that seems to me
that that should be returning a bunch of
word sense entities right not to get a
would sense entity I don't so do you
know what I'm talking about it yeah yeah
there's word since I think I saw that
once but not very familiar wait well try
entity
well no no just try it typing the entity
of would sense we don't seem to have it
yet
I'll try that yeah I mean entity lists I
tried it's probably gonna be long if I
want oh wow
any value of where it sends comma random
entity why don't you do random entity
what the hell the display
I don't know you know she might be drunk
okay okay okay hold hold on hold on hold
on hold on hold on hold on just get ten
of them just a random entity would sense
Comintern okay the way more sense is
still under development so it's okay
fine okay so what those are but they're
not properly represented there ah you
know they they were supposed to have and
we did this in the early days of Wolfram
Alpha we had a word that described the
sunsets that could be given as you know
you know compliment in the sense of
mathematics or something right not sure
why they weren't showing a priority in
there for me what as per the the
parenthetical sense associated with each
word why are you running the same
version now I'm running twelve one so
maybe that's it can you run 12 oh I said
pretty I have an old twelve one but
actually I could already know next you
want to show us but can you share your
screen neck okay you have
show your screen hello Nick maybe you're
a mute sorry yeah well are you able to
show your screen
yeah oh cool oh we've got a great big
what is that that's not relevant what
are you doing just do random entity hmm
well but you I just saw it on your
screen so it must be that some of the
senses don't include it we do simple
entities but I was just seeing this on
your screen
yeah scroll back up to where it was yeah
there's supposed to be this
parenthetical well that's really cool
okay so something's wrong with that but
we don't know what's exactly wrong with
that yeah but you get what that that
picture so that's highly relevant for
Jerome yes yes yes yes yes yes and quite
beautiful by the way in my opinion so
how would you okay so you do like
control control recall and then
disambiguate how would you you know
input such what sense I mean I think
once they're exposed you know you could
say something like still and you may get
worried as a default but you should also
have word sense as a disambiguation
option and it's just because it's in
development still it's not exposed
nobody also could imagine linguistics
still in the sense of blah blah blah
yeah III think what we could expect is
we could have a version of some kind of
text parsing thing that breaks a you
know instead of text words right we
would get text words where what comes
out is word entities I'm making sense
mmm-hmm I mean it could even be called
you know text entities or something I'm
not sure that's right
that's not right but that's what we want
is we want something which comes out as
these tagged you know in a certain sense
now this is a very inexact science and
isn't really a science at all because
word sensors are a mess and you know I
don't think we can guarantee any
stability of word sensors not least
because language evolves and so on yeah
so we thought of by the way those
sentence frames need to be in a much
more computable form you see those
sentence frames Jerome you see those
sentence frames hello Jerome Jerome are
you a mute yes exactly that's right I
see them and that's a problem we have
the to specify yes such word in context
right we don't really have a design we
just were talking we just were talking
about this we were you look so yeah we
had we had an alternative way to to
specify these sense I can show you if
you want look like a more statistical
type or by example go ahead no go ahead
so we're thinking on where which one was
it's not synonym yeah contextualize
takes pattern something like you would
say we talked about this once before
than a word yeah I understand son I see
boy
yep we talked about this once before I
mean we talked about the idea
I think of text element
what was the story of a text element and
contextualisation we already had this
discussion I remember I think I have
notes about this but the question here
you know the problem is what if there's
two apples in that second sentence I'm
sorry yeah what we need is a textual
notion of a lambda in other words what
we need is something right it's like
honestly I think this one should still
work because 99% of the time you have
only one understand understand so this
is exactly the same thing right if you
think about this like a lambda okay
what's happening is that is recognizing
you know that's yeah I mean but I don't
even think that's the right way to do it
I think there's probably some notation
that we want in the string like we need
for those sentence frames right but the
sentence frame has a pattern object
inside the string true now I mean we
could do that using string expression so
you did something like this right yeah
or actually it's
the string right it's like some special
character I don't know I mean no so one
possibility
okay so that raises the possibility okay
here's an example of possibility right
now we have string expression right
which is an extra string Euler so to
speak version of making patterns okay
what I'm potentially thinking is there
might be an interest string version of
that using special characters hmm do you
get what I'm saying yeah and that could
be equivalent to a string expression
maybe although naming them with an
external you know it's tough to see how
you would get the naming the the the
pure version of that without a name I
think could be interest string right by
the time you've got an X there you've
got to have that X agree with the X
that's in the outside world am I making
sense we're going to use name it
patterns maybe we should use some kind
of conditional like slash semicolon
something no but I'm saying look I'm
saying there are cases in which you want
an unnamed pattern or possibly an
unnamed lambda like thing right a hash
like thing inside the string right I'm
saying we could imagine doing that with
special characters by the time you need
to name it and use it externally I don't
think that will work and what's a string
someplace it sticks it does yes it does
so that's a good that's a good thing to
think about that yeah that's a good
that's it that's a good idea that string
template is another pattern for this um
mmm that's a good idea
you know that's already something where
we have the notion of naming yeah
stupid at all so I'm string template
support and name it name it yes that's
right that's correct although then
naming is a string name alright let's
just get a sense of what the what the
bigger picture is here so first thing is
we need some function that is going to
try to turn a sentence into word sense
entities right that's one thing that's
clearly useful if we can do that do you
agree yes okay so this idea what really
is this contextualized pattern is it in
fact something that is trying to
represent a word sense entity or is it
something that's floppy other than that
it could be both so was thinking of one
that would try to match the exact string
and try it was a context vector because
in implementation will transform all of
these I mean from this one into a vector
representation of this word in this
context right yeah so we try to have the
distance in this vector space you know
smaller than a special and exact match
but you could also have one that doesn't
look for the string match at all and
only operate in in the feature space and
and I would grab synonyms I would grab
you know related concept yeah
it's mean bit more fuzzy and of course
it should be way in both cases it should
be a way to offer a threshold argument
or trishul option to see how far we are
the scope of the pattern well I mean
this thing by the way I mean you know
basically there's a text pattern concept
that we can imagine that can deal with
contextualization and a bunch of other
things we call a text pattern could have
could deal with oh you seem to have that
open it up okay
this would be when you have many many of
them like defining a concept for Nepal
this will be defining the concept of
cities or maybe European cities in that
case it's pretty well hold on that's a
different thing again I mean so yeah in
image cases we've got this idea of you
know I've now forgotten what final
syntax we use for that so if you show it
you know ten examples of a cat then it
should be able to how does that work for
image cases can you remind me that
should be it yeah you should be able to
I mean not right now but the idea is to
have this semantic pattern or something
like this image semantic pattern or
image pattern object and you give many
pictures of cats to understand what a
cat is and find cats in whatever you
make sure you give right but so with
words what you're doing here is in one
sense you are trying to create a concept
by combining a bunch of words yeah yeah
and the other thing you're trying to do
is to drill down on a particular word to
look only at certain senses of that word
which are two different kinds needs two
different kind of things and also this
one is really about conceptualizing like
disambiguating while this one and you
could also do so no I'm saying one of
them is drilling down and the other one
is puffing up right so the first pattern
is drilling down the word was that you
know the word was was set for example
but there are 15 meanings of set and
this is drilling down to a specific
meaning whereas I'm thinking case what
you're doing is you're saying I want to
make a super word which is my whole
category they're true true this one is
emitting means although this one you
know with never roots and carrots as
well would say just starts from this
world I guess it's the one no but I
don't my claim is this okay words are
assert okay consider meaning space right
and consider regions in meaning space
right word
represent a particular region in meaning
space okay there can be more specific
regions in meaning space so a word what
is a word a word is something that you
know is you can think about as a
function you know as a distribution with
support in different parts of meaning
space if I'm making sense right and so a
word sense might be a thing with smaller
supporting meaning space that's just a
subset of the region with support for
the word a word would be something that
combines a bunch of kind of these
regions and meanings based that makes
sense so I claim that the the underlying
concept is essentially I mean it's
similar to learn distribution it's
essentially some distribution in meaning
space yes the underlying right so it's
some kind of concept distribution okay
so how you're poking at that concept
distribution in various different ways
so for example one concept distribution
would be there are various named concept
distributions one named concert
distribution is the word set for example
right yeah another named concept
distribution is set in the sense of a
tennis yeah yes yeah right
another named well another thing which
doesn't have a name so the Sen sets the
synonym sets and so on don't really have
names you know in in some cases okay you
know in fact English doesn't make a good
distinction between the set of fruits
and fruits right so in other words it
might be a different thing to say it's
not self-evident that fruits means
apples bananas pears whatever you know
what am I saying there is a category of
fruits and then there are individual
fruits which are members of that
category this makes sense mm-hmm and
those are those in general are are um
okay so I mean I think what we need here
is um I don't yet understand completely
what this is but it's some kind of
there's a yogya yeah but I think it's I
think the concept is going to be a text
pattern that's my guess that's the
general I'm not sure ah yeah wait Carl
on my live stream is commenting that
that you know chatbot building systems
and this is something you know we've
done since forever they let you give
some phrases and then the system can
generalize to other phrases and that's
exactly what I mean we've tried to build
a bunch of automated systems for doing
this since the early days of Wolfram
Alpha
um and I'm not sure that that and that
is similar to the you know the famous
mr. Smith mrs. Jones problem actually on
that topic it doesn't have to be a word
this could be a phrase sure or sentence
yeah it could be right but I mean so the
concept is a distribution in meaning
space and how we get to that
distribution in meaning space there are
a variety of ways to do it from named
things to neural net things to whatever
now once we have one of those things
there's a question of well what is the
question is given one of those
distributions in meaning space does that
appear with sufficient you know overlap
integral or something with some
particular thing in our piece of text
does that make sense so I'm saying so
distribution in meeting space the
question is is there anywhere in my text
that has reasonable overlap with this
distribution in meeting space and that
could mean that the thing that appears
in my text covers you know it's okay
in okay every word in the text let's say
or every phrase in the text is another
distribution in meaning space by making
sense so no well for for given texts it
would be a precise point in this base I
don't think that's true I don't think
you can determine that from a text I
think that's technically that's how
would you would put a I understand you
can get a feature except Chile but but
you know you can imagine at an ensemble
of possible feature vectors all kinds of
different ways to implement it but the
truth is that just saying one sentence
doesn't homed in on a specific point in
meaning space it might but it probably
doesn't I mean the number two right
probably has honed in on a specific
point in meaning space but for example
if you never I'm degree T even with the
contexts as well that's what I'm saying
yes I'm saying you know the um I don't
know the dinosaur will live another day
I know why I'm picking that sentence but
I'm sure we can pick that apart yeah I
mean that sentence has all kinds of
shades of meaning and it is not on its
you know that sentence on its own hmm if
that was in a whole story about how I
mean all kinds of different things that
that could mean that depend on the
ambient sort of understanding that that
so so my claim is that any that as you
go through a text that you can think of
every piece of that text as representing
some distribution in meaning space
you can also think that you are
searching with text cases for something
that quotes matches some distribution in
meeting space yeah okay but the notion
of what it means to match may be
complicated for example it could be that
the thing that appears within the text
is contained entirely within the
distribution in meaning space that you
are trying to match to you know the
distribution could be generally
describing fruits and apple and banana
could both just be you know sub
distributions inside there that would
just straight match or alternatively it
could be that the thing you're asking
for is purchase and what's in the text
is by and those have an overlapping
meaning space that make sense
oh definitely know how to make it
practical to use for users I guess
should be something quite simple I mean
I completely agree conceptually you know
that defining X something simple will be
to defining a centroid for whatever
concept we have and then distance and
then and then specify a special I don't
know if that will work the issue is you
are thinking in terms of this kind of
crazy linear vector space idea for
representing meaning which i think is
ultimately corrupt I mean okay could be
me couldn't necessarily be a centroid
it's true it could be me it could be
many things it could be a very strange
creature I mean I think that you know
that's the problem with sin sets in in
you know word net and so on that this
question of how far out you go you know
if you try and use our synonym system to
actually do something semantic it will
not work very well and then no synonym
system does because these you know where
you get to by jumping from word to word
and a synonym Network it you get a long
way because these things aren't what am
I trying to say
I'm not a great believer III can imagine
okay it's like in colorspace you go a
distance point one in color space it
means a different thing depending on
where you are in color space in word
space in meaning space I have to believe
that going point one in meaning space is
a crazy concept okay
in other words that some parts of
meaning space you know like for instance
okay let's imagine you're doing medical
stuff okay distance point one in meaning
space between a liver and a kidney might
be quite small right that those two
might be the same they might be within
point one in meaning space right but it
certainly matters you know which one of
those some diagnosis is about yet point
one distance point one in meaning space
when you're talking about am I making
any sense here I meant my point is I
don't think there's a I don't think
there's any meaningful sense in which
you can have a uniform meaning for point
one in meaning space independent of
where you are in meaning space
they are more delighted than others what
you care about because if it's if it's a
you know I mean I hate to say it but if
it's you're gonna eat the animal right
you probably don't care whether it's
this muscle of that muscle but you
certainly do care if you're trying to
you know make the animal be a better
race horse or something so I I think
it's really I'm sceptical I mean I mean
you can you can figure out kind of the
distance from the examples you know like
if I have something you're very specific
fine
they close to each other you say I mean
it's as you say is all of these points
in space we can learn the distribution
given this win of course it's only three
four is gonna be a bit hard so then we
seem very simple models right I mean you
could do in your learn distribution
system you should be able to learn a
distribution from those points yes right
and that distribution in meaning space
you'd be interesting to see what it is
you know who knows where that goes
I mean for all I know there's a you know
there's a type of cocktail that has you
know all three of those very very weird
angry but but so to make this meaningful
I mean okay so look I think this is a
super interesting conversation that um
we and I think we can do something
really good here
I think I think it needs to be a similar
kind of approach to what we're doing
with image cases yeah but I think that
the way to think about this in terms of
um yeah I think
I think we've got these various named
things like a word or word sense that's
useful we've also got these category
names which we use in things like image
identify and which in our new kind of
entity ontology we're likely to pay more
attention to that make sense so a
category name is another fact this is a
good point okay so a a concept or
category is another entity in other
words the the concept of fruits is not
the same thing as the word fruits and we
distinguish that in our system mmm and
that's a good thing because the concept
fruits is a whole bag of I mean we're
already doing some of that in in text
cases right now okay so this is another
comment so it takes cases right now we
are able to pick out entity types we're
not able to pick out entity classes
[Music]
right so for example I don't think we
could ask for fruits right now but
there's no reason syntactically we've
got a way to ask for that because we
have a concept of fruits that make sense
Durham beaut again
make sense and that seems to be
something that I could imagine us being
able to do fairly it shoroma you are you
back yet thing technical issues it's a
bit later for know well we need to wrap
this meeting up actually oh yeah I think
technical problem John definitely yeah
other things was like you know
interesting things that fixed order like
this sort of thing yeah all that stuff
exactly I think we should do it and we
discussed about oh yeah
things like you know yes much but you
know I don't care I'm insensitive to to
the case I mean since each other
critiques this sort of stuff and maybe
some way to do some tests you know the
condition so anyway that's there's a
quite different thing which is lemma
ties Asian and inflections and so on and
there's a separate project which was
supposed to happen which was curating
inflections of words this one issue
though they're also in contexts to be
correct of course just part of speech is
enough to disambiguates probably no no
it's not it's not it's not simply not I
mean this is the this is the same thing
yes we will need words in context you
know again alright we should look at the
live stream here and then we should try
and wrap this meeting actually we have
another live stream meeting coming right
up after this um ok South is asking
about an LP glove nets and the
repository don't include networks used
for training I suspect that's for
licensing reasons but I don't know maybe
to she too knows these true we should
set up training networks as well okay we
are positioned to do that it's I think
so we can create us ourself I don't
think we had access but we can create
the Train
because it's not the first person I
asked for how do I train my own words
actors right so it should be not too
hard to set up okay that's the
two-seater st I think yeah with with
your hormone simile to help um Carl is
talking about wiki data having a lexemes
thing I don't know anything about that I
mean I know what a lexeme is I think um
yes the whole business about being able
to do offline processing with grammar
rules that is coming slightly slowly but
it is coming we are not far away from
being able to have a standalone version
of that um
Carl is saying better usage flow for
neural networks as feature extractors
and classify I thought that was pretty
good
don't we have isn't doesn't classify
have could you could you just show that
for a second @n yeah sure so what well
how you use feature extractors in
classify I thought it's just an option
to classify yes classify then its
feature extract all and it can be a
named one or it can be it can be a
function as well that looks pretty clean
to me I think I think Kyle needs to try
the latest version you can also creates
feature extraction before and then
include it to classify let's important
by the way in practice yes
so either yeah you know either a
training or afterward that's also
interesting I can say then I extract
features of the data then a classifier
with these features and then you say Oh
actually I need to happen to prepend
that you can do it with testify of
function I believe feature extract tour
and then we put the feet to the previous
feature extractor you just articles I
just turned red that's true that's true
if you think of it classify again
are interesting yes you can do feature
extractor we are we we forgot to add it
to the table that's why it's ready
okay at a bug um okay well let's wrap
this up um this is interesting stuff we
should continue it not too long and talk
about when we continue we probably need
hum sorry because that there's no bug
it's just classified sinister treasure
at all okay
you read your classifier on the
classifier function yes yes this is a
classifier like in science there okay
next iteration of this we probably do we
have anybody project managing here
enya oh okay you've been very quiet okay
I was reporting I mean I was taking down
all the bugs though good the UM okay
I think we're gonna need Alan and a
future discussion of this because I
would like to make sure that this
dovetails with all the stuff we're doing
on curation of words and word senses and
so on I would also like to know what
happened to the inflections project
that's it's good do you know anything
about that was that ended up in your
team or not the inspections pray well I
was looking at that for localization
that's right okay so I think that's with
Alan so we here would have to be part of
this thing okay terrific thanks um
thanks to local folk thanks for comments
on the live stream and if you're into
live streaming we will be in about five
minutes we will be doing another one um
All Right see y'all soon